[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAYMOND PENG: Hello, everyone.
And welcome to today's webcast
about API Governance 2.0,
a key element for security
and scaling API programs.
My name is Raymond Peng,
and I'm a digital engagement
lead at Google.
And I'm also joined
with Ruben Gonzalez.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Hi, everyone.
I'm a customer
engineer for Apigee.
RAYMOND PENG: Awesome.
All right, so before
we get started,
just a quick few
housekeeping items.
You're going to see on the
console in this webcast
on the left a
place where you can
put in your queue and
questions and answers.
You can post your questions at
any time during the webcast.
But please note that
you don't have to wait
until the end of the session.
You can ask at any time.
I'll try to answer
them either at the end
or offline after the webcast.
Also, you'll see a
resource list on the right.
We will post some
links and other things
within the resource that we
mentioned during the webcast
so you can access
them as well that way.
So let's take a quick look at
the agenda for today's webcast.
The first thing we're
going to talk about
is a paradigm shift
in API governance.
So what is this API governance
2.0 all about anyways?
We're also going to
start with creating
consistent and security
API patterns for APIs
and how you can use them to
ensure adherence and compliance
and standards for your APIs.
And then we'll show you how
Apigee can help you do that.
So the software that
applies this API governance
2.0 concepts, as well
as the technology.
And hopefully they'll
help our audience
understand how they can
build and test APIs much,
much faster than
they're doing today.
So with that being
said, let's take a look
at where companies are at.
A lot of companies
have invested in APIs.
They might have hundreds
or even thousands of APIs.
And those who have
them are primarily
started with this integration
method, basically APIs that
were calling system to system.
But you know, with
digital disruption, Ruben,
so many things have happened
in terms of emergence of cloud,
the changing power
of the consumer,
and the emergence of
new competitive threats
for a lot of different companies
in terms of other crossovers
that are trying to get
their business away.
So now companies are
starting to use APIs
in a much more expansive way.
They are integrating
with partners.
So they're going external.
They're putting
them on the cloud.
And they're using them to
monetize and actually find
new sources of revenue.
So really transformative.
But in the end, so
now you've got-- maybe
you had 10, 100, or 1,000 APIs,
but they were all internal.
But now they're also external.
And so that creates
this concern that you
have all these APIs
in your organization,
internal or external.
But at the same time,
you still got to go fast.
And there's that
concern about security.
So there's this balance in terms
of, well, I've got to go fast.
I need to be competitive.
But how can I get this speed?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That's right.
And we usually see this
happening too often.
So now organizations
are thinking
of security as an afterthought
rather than something
that needs to be prioritized
even before thinking
of which capabilities
they're going
to start exposing through APIs.
They're getting
all this pressure
from their competition.
They need to deliver
as fast as possible.
However, you see, all
these security issues
are not being
addressed correctly.
And then surprise, now
they're being attacked,
or now some malicious
user found a vulnerability
and now they're using all their
data for malicious purposes.
So yeah, this is
happening too often.
So how did we come
to this place?
How did this come to happen?
And well, it's pretty simple.
So organizations, they want
to innovate really fast.
However, it's not as simple as
just exposing some [? detail ?]
assets through an API.
Yeah, of course,
they need to deliver
all these new experiences
as fast as possible.
However, they're still
dealing with the same legacy
and old systems.
And some development
themes, they're
just exposing services
just because they can.
They're just building
a REST interface
on top of their legacy
systems, and they're
forgetting about setting
the right security patterns.
Perhaps they're not
thinking how they
should be a scaling
their APIs the right way.
They are losing
visibility on who
are the real users of those
APIs so that whenever they bring
a new revision or a new
update to their services,
they lose control of
the updates that they're
making to those systems.
In a sense, they're creating
this API sprawl environment.
So they are losing
control of what's going on
within the API program.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah,
it's a real problem.
And it's like the more you
create APIs, it is a benefit,
but it creates lots of
different security holes,
and especially if you're
doing them all differently.
And so a lot of
companies are looking
at the typical IT method,
which is big G Governance.
So I'm going to put rules,
gates, and enforcements.
I'm going to make sure that I'm
controlling every little thing,
and that there's
approvals for releases
and lots of manual reviews.
That accompanies
with big documents
and also a lot of
different time spent
on aligning and
corporate politics.
So it's a problem, Ruben, right?
So we've got all these
security concerns.
We've got to go fast.
But because of that
security, now we
have this big cop in the middle.
And that's pretty-- that
can be really detrimental.
And so if you look at
it from a standpoint,
let's say we've got an API team.
They're ready to release their
APIs or build their APIs.
They start out happy.
But they get to this
first standpoint,
which is they have an
architecture review.
So now that's a speed bump.
Then they have to go
to API design review.
Someone has to make
sure that they're
using the right approach
and they're reusable,
and making sure they have
the right policies in there.
Or they have an internal
standards review.
And then finally when
they go to deploy,
there's a whole
bunch of checklists
that they never were aware of.
And so what happens in
these four speed bumps?
There's done tons of
rework within the cycle.
And so if you're a
smart team, you're
going to prepare in
advance and you're
going to get all
your documents ready.
But this process is
probably such a headache
that you start to bundle
all of your APIs together.
So rather than
getting one approved,
I'm going to put 20 or 30.
And so pretty soon
we're back to waterfall.
The other thing is I know
some of the loopholes.
I know I have relationships,
I know people.
And I know what they're kind of
looking for, or they know me.
So I might just
sidestep this process.
And in the end,
what happens there?
Something that we designed
to keep us secure is now,
people have found a
loophole and found
the path of least resistance.
So this is a real bad problem.
So it looks like
there's no good way
to solve this, right, Ruben?
I mean, I think
that's the challenge
of where we are today.
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
I mean, there are
different in the ways of
how we can address this.
We can see this as a
process-driven solution,
or perhaps making a mix,
including as part of the mix
the right tool for you to be
able to address these issues.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah, and so
before we get into tools--
I think as
technologists, we always
think about how
can we use tools?
I think the most important thing
that we find with our customers
and organizations, it's
really a mindset shift first.
And so at Apigee, we call
it API Governance 2.0.
And we wrote this manifesto
working with hundreds
of customers worldwide.
And we've seen
their programs grow
based on this kind of mindset.
And so the first one is really
around empowering and enabling
over enforcement.
How can I help my API
teams, give them the tools,
give them knowledge, give them
the ability to make decisions?
Then the second is guidance
and support over policing.
The third is accelerating
progress over slowing change.
So really it's a dynamic.
I'm not focused on how can I
overturn everything and look
at it?
I really want to focus on speed.
What can I do to keep
these things going fast?
And last is this relinquishing
of a centralized control.
So trust and federation
over centralized control.
I think trust is not
something that you can just
basically say trust me.
You have to build
trust into your system.
So that's the
cornerstone, I think,
of the mindset change, this
manifesto of Governance 2.0.
And so that really
means a lot of teams,
they call them API
centers of Excellence.
But what we want
people to shift to
is this API center
of enablement.
And so what does that look like?
I think really quickly,
Big G governance
versus little g culture.
That's really the shift in
terms of Big G governance
to this Governance 2.0.
It means I'm going from
rules, gates, and enforcements
to principles, standards,
and empowerment.
I used to have top-down design
and planning and big waterfall.
Now I have separation
of concerns.
I have an enterprise concern.
I allow teams to do
what they need to do.
I'm going from
approvals for releases
to criteria-based and
continuous releases.
I want people to understand
what it means to pass Go
and to hit the criteria so
that they can always release
constantly at their speed.
And I'm not going to do
manual and analog processes.
I'm going to look at how
I can create self-service
through automation and tooling.
And I'm going to enforce
community knowledge
and community documentation,
rather than centralized Word
documents.
And then the last couple, too.
I'm going to have
cross-functional teams
and coaches.
I'm not going to have distinct
big handovers from teams, which
is very core to the
way of agile thinking,
the same thing as
Governance 2.0.
And instead of spending all
this time aligning and building
corporate politics, I'm going to
focus on building tools, CI/CD,
to help the teams go faster
so that they're essentially
using efficiency based
tools rather than alignment
and time spent on wasted
on meetings and politics.
If I have that, I have this
API Governance 2.0, Ruben.
Let's take a look at the
process that we have today.
There's four points, API
architecture, design,
standards, and then
deployment and live.
So how can we use
technology in this case, how
can we apply the principles
of API 2.0 to all four
of these things?
Let's do that and try to
solve this problem together.
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
Definitely, so from
an architectural
standpoint, perhaps you
might want to look into a
way to standardize globally
and across all your
existing architecture.
It doesn't matter
if you are deploying
on a cloud or multiple cloud
providers or even on premises.
You want to build a
layer of abstraction
on top of your
existing services so
that you can enforce and not
only enforce, but decouple
common security patterns
from your existing
system, supporting
your existing APIs so
that you're going
to be able to build
this layer of abstraction.
And essentially,
this will become
a shield that is going to
protect both the interactions
from your existing
API consumers and also
the secure interactions between
this platform and your back end
systems.
By setting up this
layer of abstraction,
you're going to be able to
standardize all your security
patterns and make sure that
they are enforced correctly.
RAYMOND PENG: Perfect.
So if I'm an API
developer, I deploy an API
to the API platform,
I'm automatically
going to gain the
benefits of threat
protection, the security,
and the patterns
that you're talking about.
So I'm essentially deploying
on a trusted platform.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
So essentially you're
building secure interactions
between your API consumers
and your back end systems
through a standardized shield or
layer of abstraction in an API
Platform.
RAYMOND PENG: What are some of
the examples of the patterns
that you're talking
about, Ruben?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: So perhaps
from a network perspective,
you're going to be building
trust relationships
within the platform and
your back end systems.
Perhaps you're already using
an existing security pattern.
So the only thing
you need to do is
to set up a really simple trust
relationship between the API
platform and your
existing back end systems.
Perhaps you can build up a
very simple mutual TLS setup.
Perhaps if you're looking into
token based authentication
mechanisms, that's something
you can build upon.
However, if you want to
reuse what you already have,
you can do it.
And then you can keep
progressing those patterns
so that you can
start standardizing
once new projects come in.
And the same story goes on
the consumer relationship.
Perhaps your
organization might be
thinking on setting up OAuth
as a standard across the board.
That's something that you
can enforce at this layer.
RAYMOND PENG: Perfect, perfect.
So I've got my API
management setup now.
I've got the security
architecture in place.
You talked a little bit
about OAuth and security.
Can you tell me a little bit
more about-- now let's dive in.
I've got a couple of APIs.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Definitely.
So usually from a
development standpoint--
this happens too often.
Each and every time you have
to expose a new service,
we developers need to
sometimes get too creative
and start setting up new
security pattern, or new ways
to secure our project or APIs.
And for each and every project,
we have to set up that pattern.
However, there's a
best way to do it.
So once you build this
layer of abstraction,
perhaps you can also start
decoupling this pattern
so that no longer is it going
to be the developer's task
to have to come up with
a new security pattern.
Then essentially after
decoupling these patterns,
you're essentially creating
shareable libraries.
And in this case, you can
decouple an authentication
and authorization shared
library through a policy.
And now the developer doesn't
have to come up with all this.
And then he can really
focus on the business value
that he's going to be
exposing through an API.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah.
We love creativity, but not when
it comes to security, right?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
RAYMOND PENG: We want to do
best practice and standardize.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly.
And remember, security's
not all about just
authentication
and authorization.
Perhaps you want to protect
your APIs against DDoS attacks,
or perhaps against
content-based attacks.
That's something
that, again, is great
that you're thinking of
on those different issues.
However, you just need to have
to come up with those patterns
once, and perhaps
the person in charge
of designing or
identifying those patterns
is a completely
different stakeholder
than from a web
developer standpoint.
Perhaps within your
own organization
you already have a
security team that
is in charge of making sure
these patterns are applied
correctly throughout
all the APIs
that you're going
to be exposing.
So you will need to
have the right tool that
will enable you to have
the separation of duties.
The developer team, the API team
will focus on the real business
value that we're going to
be exposing through APIs.
And of course, the
security stakeholders
are going to treat
these shared security
policies as a
non-functional requirement.
Although they are
very important,
you just need to come
up with them once
and then you don't have
to worry about them.
You can keep
redeploying new APIs
and you don't need to do that
all the revalidation process
for these specific
aspects of your releases.
RAYMOND PENG: So it's
almost like the path
of least resistance.
If I'm a developer,
and I'm creating APIs,
I mean, you're actually making
my life a little easier.
I just got to focus
on the request
and response of the payload
and the business logic there.
But all the stuff around
the shared security policies
is no longer a thing that I
have to be concerned with.
If I deploy on the
API platform, I'm
automatically getting some
of these policies for free.
They're added already, right?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
And still, you might want
to have the right tool just
because you will
still want to have
a certain level of flexibility.
Perhaps you're going to come up
with specific parameters that
are going to be able to let the
API team to decide which rate
or quotas you're going to
be applying for API or API
product.
So again, you still want to
have that separation of concerns
in regards of
policy enforcement.
However, there
are certain levels
of parameterizing
options you might
want to leave to be the
responsibility of the API
team or even the business team.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
So I get that flexibility.
And also, anybody who uses the
platform says, hey, security's
already been involved.
They've actually been
part of the architecture
of the policies even
that are being added,
which is really great.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Remember, we're
talking about artifacts here.
So every software
product nowadays
has to go through a software
development lifecycle.
And the best way to
do all these releases
is through an agile process.
So thinking in terms of an
API platform and everything
that you're going to be
deploying within this tool,
we're thinking in
configuration terms.
So usually, we have to train
these configuration artifacts
as if they were any
other software artifact.
So they're going to
have a release process.
They're going to have specific
stages where you might want
to run some quality checks.
And you're going to
want to make sure
that you're applying and
making sure the right security
policies are being enforced
even before deploying
this configuration
into the platform.
After these
configuration artifacts
are deployed into
the platform, you
want to make sure that even
though they were already
pre-validated, once
you deploy them,
you can re-run some tests to be
able to have a full integration
test results, from
the consumer side
all the way to your
back end systems.
So again, you will have
even multiple security--
this kind of
lifecycle will enable
you to have multiple security
checks before deploying,
and even after deploying.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice,
so there's a lot
of tools in the CI/CD pipeline
that you're talking about,
right?
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
Yeah, definitely.
And the beauty of it is that
every customer is different,
and as well every
customer might be
in a different stage in
regards of their maturity level
on using agile
software development
lifecycle and pipelines.
So most organizations want to be
able to reuse what they already
got.
You don't want to
get a platform that
is going to force you to
choose a specific set of tools.
You want to have flexibility.
And that's great from a
development standpoint.
You don't need to
rethink the wheel.
If you already used to handle
Java source code, most likely
you're going to be relating
very often to Maven.
So you might want to
have an option for you
to be able to
deploy configuration
artifacts through Maven.
So that's something that Apigee
provides for our customers.
So another thing if you're
perhaps a web developer,
you might be more comfortable
using JavaScript based tools.
So also Apigee offers
some plugins for you
to be able to
deploy configuration
artifacts into the platform
using JavaScript plug-ins.
And again, the sky's the limit.
If you're already using a CI/CD
orchestrator, such as Jenkins,
that's something that
you can reuse and build
a pipeline for all
these artifacts
that you're going to be
pushing into the platform.
Thinking about source
control, each and every
[? major ?] organization that
handles software development,
of course, they
might have chosen
a specific version or a specific
product for source control.
So that's something
that is really
standard in the
industry, and actually we
promote it as a best practice
also for our configuration
artifacts.
RAYMOND PENG: So Apigee
is really flexible, right?
We can adapt to all these tools.
I think back to
the security point,
is we see a lot of companies
who are using and adding
linting tools.
They're adding their
security testing tools.
They're adding custom
regular expressions
and other types
of quality checks
right into the CI/CD pipeline.
So when they're deploying their
APIs through the CI/CD process,
it's actually going
through additional checks,
both security, compliance, and
any other kind of standards
that they're trying to govern.
That's the power of the CI/CD,
is that they're mastering
and they're automating it
through this deployment
process.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah.
So what happens
about, not on live,
what can we do about monitoring?
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
So once your APIs
are exposed to the
public, of course,
you might want to still be
able to monitor what's going on
within your API program.
You want to be able to address
specific threats, or even
malicious users
that might be, well,
trying to break your
existing systems
or trying to steal
your information.
So you want to have
a platform that
will allow you to
define monitoring alerts
and then for you can
be able to investigate
what's going on into the
platform in real time
and act upon it.
So something that is pivotal
for any kind of platform,
and of course it's very
important for a platform that
is going to be sitting
right in the middle
within your API consumers
and your back-end systems.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah.
Sounds like a really
good tool to have,
especially when I have
thousands of APIs or hundreds
and I really don't how
much protection I have,
and if people have been
deploying in the past
and I haven't been
able to manage them.
This is a great way to monitor.
So let's take a look at some
of these things in action.
So Ruben's going
to open up Apigee.
We're going to take a look at,
when we talk about enterprise
policies and how we're
securing them and reusing them,
Ruben's going to show that.
We're going to show you the
developer experience, which
is from a developer standpoint
how does that look like.
And then we just talked
about monitoring security.
So let's take a look at those
dashboards that are coming out
of the box from Apigee.
So let's get going and let's
take a look at the demo.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: The
first time you're
going to be logging into the
platform, this is the screen
that you're going to see.
Within the Apigee Edge
platform, essentially you're
going to be deploying
configuration artifacts.
Today we're going to be showing
two different configuration
artifacts.
So we're going to be showing API
proxies and also share flows.
OK, so let's get going.
So I'm going to click
over here in API proxies.
Over here, each and every
one of these entries
that you see on the screen
represents an API proxy.
An API proxy essentially
is a configuration artifact
that will allow you to augment
the capabilities of the end
points that you're exposing
through the platform.
Some examples of this
augmentation capabilities,
perhaps you're thinking of
enforcing security patterns,
perhaps some language
mediation, perhaps some traffic
management.
Those are the kind of
patterns that you're
going to be decoupling
from your back end systems
and you want to enforce
them within the platform.
OK, so I already prepared
some APIs beforehand.
OK, so we have some Zip Codes,
Payments, and Employees APIs.
So I'm going to start
getting to the Zip Codes API.
So once I get in, I'm going to
switch into the developed app.
So as you can see, this is a
pretty straightforward API.
We have two different endpoints
exposed through my API,
OK, zip codes and cities.
OK, so now let's try it out.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
I always wanted to
[INAUDIBLE] some zip codes.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Oh yeah.
Within the platform, you have--
well, from an API
developer perspective,
you will have the Trace tool.
The Trace tool will enable
you to have a memory
picture of what's going
on within the traffic
flow of your API.
So the only thing that I need to
do is to start a trace session.
OK.
Once it's started, I can
send over a transaction.
OK, and then I hit Send.
And immediately,
I'm getting a 401.
So as you can see, I'm enforcing
two different policies.
One of them is a DDoS
Protection policy.
And the second one is a
Verify API Key policy.
But wait a minute.
If I go back to
my Develop tab, I
don't see any policy being
enforced in my flows.
I see if I take a look at
the preflow, I see no policy.
If I get into the Cities
resource, I see no policy.
I have a policy defined here.
But however, this
little broken link image
here is telling me that it's
not attaching to my flow.
So what's going on?
Who's enforcing those APIs?
Well, me as an API developer
within my organization,
I only have this
Development view for my API.
However, someone up in
the chain of command
within my organization
is already
enforcing security
policies globally.
Let's take a look at that.
So now I'm going
to switch roles.
And now I'm going to become
Ruben Gonzalez, the security
stakeholder.
Me as a security stakeholder,
I will have access
to a different configuration
artifact called shared flows.
OK, so over here
within share flows,
I already have one that
is defined as Share Flow
Enterprise Security.
So let's take a look at it.
OK, within share flows, I
also have a developed app.
So you should think of share
flows as shareable libraries.
Essentially, you're going to
be coming up with patterns,
and these patterns
are essentially
policies that are
attached together
within an execution flow.
So in this case,
have a single flow.
And this is the policies I
already have preattached.
OK, so as you can see, well,
we call it enterprise security
because mostly
all these policies
are going to be addressing
security scenarios.
So in this case,
this first policy
is making sure
that our back-ends
are going to be protected
against the DDoS attacks.
And we are allowing a rate of
100 transactions per second.
Within the second
policy, I'm enforcing
a very simple
authentication mechanism,
which is verify API key.
However, the Apigee
Edge platform
is not limited to the
simple security pattern.
Actually, remember, we offer
multiple security policies.
So let's take a look
at that category.
OK, so if I click over
here in Add Policy,
you're going to be able to
see the three main categories
for our out-of-the-box policy.
So if we take a look at
the security policies,
you're going to be able to see,
well, there are multiple ones.
And within the
platform, let's say
if you're interested in
using a token-based mechanism
to authenticate each and
every API call, of course
within the platform, you can use
JWTs, JWT tokens, J-W-T tokens.
You can use SAML
assertions, for example.
You can use encrypted tokens.
You can use basic
authentication.
If you're looking forward to
enforce OAuth across the board,
of course, you
can do it as well.
OK, so there are multiple
options within the platform.
And of course, there's
a lot of flexibility
for you to choose and
enforce the right pattern
depending on your business.
OK?
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Awesome.
So again, there
are multiple ones.
Remember, security
isn't all about just
authorization and
authentication.
Perhaps you may also want
to restrict and protect
your back-end systems against
content-based attacks.
And these two next policies
address exactly that.
So this first one protects
your back end systems
against SQL injection attacks.
And the second one is
protecting your back-end systems
against code injection attacks.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Makes sense?
So now that I--
me, as a security stakeholder,
defined this shared function
within my organization,
then there's
an extra way I can make sure
that no one can do anything
about it and it's going
to be enforced globally.
And for that, we're going to
be using our global environment
configuration.
And within our
environments, we're
going to have what
we call flow hooks.
So there are three
main flow hooks
in an environment within the
Apigee Edge organization.
So essentially, flow
hooks are execution points
for the interactions between the
API consumer and the platform,
and of course, the platform
and the back end systems.
But these execution points
are exactly at the edges,
meaning the developer will not
be able to touch these edges.
These are policies and sections
that are enforced globally.
OK, so I'm going to
switch environment here.
I'm going to switch to my
development environment.
And as you can see,
well, here it is.
My global enterprise
security policy
is being enforced
at the pre-proxy.
The pre-proxy flow
hook is guaranteed
to execute before the
transaction reaches your API
proxy.
Therefore, the API
developer will not
be able to manage or
to change this setting.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
So any API deployed to
the test environment
is going to go through these
enterprise security policies
that you just said
in the pre-proxy.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
RAYMOND PENG: And I don't have
to do anything as a developer
to do that.
Which is, I think, a big
difference from big G
governance where you
give somebody a document,
or you say, this is a process
and we're going to check.
There's nothing here.
You deploy.
It'll automatically happen.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly.
Now the developer is
going to be able to focus
on really defining a nice,
RESTful contract for the APIs.
And now they're going
to be able to expose
those APIs in a very nice way.
And they don't have to
worry and to come up
or to get too creative
with a security pattern.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah, perfect.
And I see you also have
a post flow there, too.
So that means if
you have a logging
policy or any other
things that you
want to do after you
get the response back,
we see a lot of the post
target as well, right?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Now, we know
that our security stakeholder,
me as Ruben Gonzalez as
a security stakeholder,
I'm able to [? import ?] these
kind of policies globally.
Now you're going to
be able also to deploy
new APIs without having to
worry about all these security
partners.
Now let's take a look at
our monitoring dashboard.
So within the
platform, remember, you
will have the ability
to set up some rules,
and for you to be able
to validate and make sure
that you're going to be able
to monitor and investigate
a specific security scenario
that me as a stakeholder,
I'm going to be interested in.
OK, so let's take a look to
our API monitoring dashboard.
So over here, you're going to be
able to define your own alerts.
And these alerts are
based on metadata
that is captured by the
platform in real time
for each and every transaction
that is going through.
OK, so let's take a
look over to our alerts
that we already predefined.
OK, so now a common use case
for a security stakeholder
is going to be, well, I'm going
to be interested in failed
authentication attempts.
I'm going to make sure that,
well, I'm not being attacked
or a malicious user is
not trying to overwhelm
my authorization services.
So in this case, I'm going
to create a new alert.
In this case, this
alert is going
to be called
Unauthorized Access.
OK.
It's going to be deployed
in the test environment.
OK, and I'm going to
set up some conditions.
So initially, we're going to
set up a basic metric, which
is going to be status code.
And me as the
security stakeholder,
I'm going to be very interested
in 401s, because this error
relates to unauthorized access.
Now let's define a threshold.
In this case, I'm going
to define the threshold
as Account.
And I'm only going to allow
10 unauthorized attempts
every five minutes.
I'm going to add
an extra dimension.
In this case, I'm going to
select the proxy, the API
proxies as my dimension.
And this condition is going to
be applied to all available API
proxies within an environment.
Remember, ultimately
the API platform
sits on top of all your
existing back end systems.
It doesn't matter where
they are deployed.
So you want the
right tool for you
to be able to manage these
flexible deployments.
In this case, I'm able
to scope down conditions
to the API level.
However, this
condition is a global--
I'm sorry, this
filter is a global one
that is going to be
applied throughout all
the available APIs
in the environment.
And also, it's going to applied
throughout all available
regions within my organization.
Remember, you want
a solution that
can be deployed in
multiple environments.
OK, so now that I
set up my conditions,
I'm going to be able to
create notification channels.
Within my alert, I can define
multiple notification channels.
In this case, we support
four main channels, which
is going to be email, Slack--
it's a very common tool
that nowadays DevOps teams
use all the time.
If you already
have PagerDuty, you
can integrate that very easily.
Or even if you have a
completely different set up,
or custom setup for you to be
able to be notified, of course,
we can integrate to
that using a webhook.
OK, so as you can
see, Ray, there's
a lot of flexibility how
not only Ops teams, but also
security stake holders
are going to be
able to monitor
specific patterns
and react accordingly
in real time.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice. so it's
a kind of a nice rules engine
to find out issues and
to proactively notify.
It's great.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly.
RAYMOND PENG: What about
from a security standpoint?
You mentioned the
security dashboards
and looking at policies
and seeing if the APIs were
adhering to that.
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
Yeah, remember we
discussed multiple approaches.
We mentioned security
from a design standpoint,
from a non-functional
requirement standpoint.
We also talked about
automation, how
you can perform specific checks
even before deploying your API
proxy configuration.
But now let's talk about once
your APIs are deployed, then
how do you make sure
that you're going
to be able to audit what's
going on in the API proxies
that your developers are
deploying into the platform?
And for that, we're going
to be using our security
and reporting capabilities.
OK, let's take a look at
our configuration dashboard.
So over here, this
is a single view
of which policies are
being enforced or used
within an environment.
OK, in this case, I'm going to
switch to the test environment.
Actually, I already have
another environment prepared
for you guys,
because this one will
have way more APIs than the
ones that we [INAUDIBLE]..
RAYMOND PENG: Oh,
there's a lot here, yeah.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly.
So in this case, as you can
see, this a single point
of view of what's going
on each and every APIs
that is being deployed.
So in this case, I'm able to
see if these APIs are receiving
traffic from a
secured protocols,
meaning all this traffic
is being encrypted or not.
Also in this case, you're
going to see multiple policies,
policy categories that
are being applied or used
within an API proxy.
In this case, if I click
on the istio-auth proxy,
I'm making sure that, well,
specific security policy
are being enforced.
Also, remember security is
not about authentication
and authorization, but
also about making sure
that, well, if someone
is deploying some custom
code within your API
proxy configuration,
you want to make sure that,
well, these developers are not
using any strange JavaScript
libraries, for instance.
So you want to make sure
that security checks were
enforced even before
deploying, and once deployed,
that nothing has changed.
RAYMOND PENG: So
this is pretty cool.
So if I look at all this,
I can just by looking at it
say, BO_authentication
and this ConsentsAPI,
there's no security policies
there against those.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
And that's a big no no.
Me as a stakeholder would
say, well, what went wrong?
Who green-lighted the
deployment of that proxy?
What's going on?
[INAUDIBLE]
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah,
let's go figure that out.
Nice.
So this is really a
nice comprehensive view.
It was really a bird's
eye view about the APIs
and what security
policies are using.
That's awesome, Ruben.
Thank you.
With all the information
that we saw-- so
we saw the enterprise policies
being enforced automatically.
We understood a little bit
about the API Platform.
And we talked about where we
can apply rules and automation
into all of this.
So let's take a look
back at our use case.
So we've got our API team.
They're really happy.
But they're about to be
unhappy, because they're
going to hit all these speed
bumps, these big four speed
bumps that we have here.
So if we used our automation,
our Governance 2.0 approach,
and we use this API management
function, what would happen?
So let's take the first
step, Architecture Review.
I would say, Ruben, that we
don't need an architecture
review at this point, right?
If we already stood
up Apigee, we've
got API management
platform, I would
say the architecture
review's happened.
We've stood up the API
management platform.
Any new API doesn't have
to do another review.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
So now remember, and
the whole point of it
is for you to [INAUDIBLE]
couple all these patterns
and apply them globally.
RAYMOND PENG: Perfect.
So that saves us a lot
of time for the API team.
So they're still
happy at this point.
What about on API design?
So if I go to API
design, and I'm already
putting in the policies-- or
actually, I didn't have to.
If I'm already deploying
APIs, and the policies
are being automatically enforced
through those flow hooks
that you showed us, security
has already signed off.
I mean, at this point,
the only other thing
is really around on my payload.
So I would say at
this point anything
that I have deployed is
already built in at runtime.
So again, I have saved
some time there, as well,
on the API design front.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That is correct.
Before deploying, and
even after deploying,
you can make sure
that nothing is
going on, even through
automation or through the tool.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice, OK, and then
I'm about to do a pull request.
My tech lead is going to
take a look at my code.
The good news is if I deploy
in the new Governance 2.0,
and if we put in lint
and tools, we've actually
done other security callouts
to something like a check
marks or something, or any other
kind of regular expressions,
I'd say at this point for
internal standards review,
I've already
automated per build.
So as a developer, I know what
I'm going to be tested against.
I can run it during
my build time.
And I could see the results.
So again, I would say Ruben,
I'm going to put an X here.
We don't have to hit
that speed bump any more
for the internal
standards review, as well.
What do you think?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly, again.
Either through
[? the tool ?] or automation,
you can make sure
that you're working
with the right patterns.
And you're going to be
able to see the reports.
RAYMOND PENG: Nice.
So my rework cycle has
already gone down by a lot.
So what about the last one?
I'm going to hit
this deployment,
I'm talking to the ops teams.
Certainly, I think given most
companies and organizations
we worked with,
there's probably still
a need for somebody to
manually hit the button, just
to make sure things are right.
But essentially
providing the information
and generating the report
about what's been done,
I would say that we can generate
these results automatically
and get them to the
ops folks so that they
can do a final approval.
So maybe not a full two slashes,
but I would say we probably
cut that time down in
about half or even more
by auto generating for ops and
getting that final approval
on the deployment.
What would you say
to that, Ruben?
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
Yeah, it might change
depending on the industry.
There are some
folks out there that
might be used to have many, many
more checks before deploying
something into production.
Perhaps if you're in
the financial industry,
perhaps you're going to have way
more stages than even the ones
that we already
covered here today.
So it changes a lot.
And also it changes
depending on the maturity
level for your DevOps teams.
RAYMOND PENG: Yep,
it certainly changes.
But I think in
general, what we see
here is that you're reducing
a lot of that effort
that a lot of teams have already
had to incur because of the way
governance was set up before.
So with these
modern tools, we've
totally been able to
launch a lot faster.
And I think the best
part is most of this
is built into the process.
So the design is built in.
The quality, the
security, and the testing
is built into the development
lifecycle, rather at the end.
That's the part that is also
saving us a ton of rework
and a ton of wasted time that's
been happening in the past.
Let's recap, Ruben.
Let's take a look.
Let's take a look at the
key takeaways for API.
So you've got hundreds
of APIs, maybe thousands,
and you got to deliver them
at speed, scale, and quality.
What's the top things
that you need to consider?
Number one is shift
your thinking.
API governance 2.0 is about
a center of enablement,
not a center of excellence.
You are not in
command and control.
You're there to enable
and empower the API teams
within the lines of business
within your enterprise
to go faster.
And you help them get there
with real quality tools.
The second is architect
security up front
with an API management
platform, something like Apigee.
When we build APIs, when
we build that management
platform with the
API with Apigee,
we're working with security.
You've got security involved in
the design of the architecture.
That ensures a trusted
platform set up from day one.
The third, and what
Ruben has showed you
around centralizing
the security policies,
you no longer have to make it an
obligation for every developer
to do these things.
Now you can centralize.
That creates a
separation of concern.
Let security in, let them
be part of the enforcement
of these policies.
And not only is it about
setting the policy,
it's about including
them at runtime.
You actually don't have
to give anybody documents.
Any time you deploy an
API, automatically built
into the runtime.
That's a real powerful
governance enforcement
right there.
And it also makes the
lives of the developers
easy because they don't
have to worry about it.
That's a nice check there.
So what's the fourth one?
Standardize the inclusion
of enterprise policies.
So whenever you've started to
create these security policies
and you standardize
them, you're also
looking at ways on how
to automatically produce
more policies that might protect
the company from other things.
So it's not just about
security, but it's also
about SQL injections or threats
or quotas or traffic management
policies that might be important
to include at an enterprise
level.
So look for ways to
standardize more of that
and reduce the developer load.
And then last of all,
there was a lots of tools
that Apigee can work
with to automate your QA
and your compliance.
So include that.
That's really sort of that last
mile in terms of development.
Build quality into
your pipeline.
Use the CI/CD
automated and include
standards and compliance
checks in your CI/CD pipeline.
So with all of
that, I think we've
captured some of the
key ways for teams
that we've seen produce APIs
at speed, scale, and quality.
And it's really following
the Governance 2.0 method
and leveraging the Apigee
management platform.
If you're interested
in all of this,
I'll invite you to get started.
If you are already
an Apigee customer,
just visit and take a
look at our Docs page.
We'll post this up
in our resources.
And if you're new
to Apigee, you can
get started right away with
a free trial of Apigee Edge.
Just follow that link
and see how easy it is.
I mean, you saw
Ruben use the tool.
You see him-- some
of it's essentially
using drag-and-drop features.
And we have APIs
from Apigee that
allow you to do a lot
of that from your ID
or other applications
that you're using.
So it's a really
easy and quick start.
So with that, we're getting
close to the end of our webinar
session.
I'd like to take a
look and see if any
questions that we have out there
from the audience to answer.
And we'll take a look.
And yeah, we have a couple.
So let's get started.
What are the-- first question.
What types of roles
and skill sets
are needed to develop
this level of automation?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: I
would say that it
varies a lot, depending
on the maturity
level within a developer team.
So if you're already leaning
towards agile software
development lifecycles and
already looking into automation
and building a pipeline for
your software artifacts,
then moving into this approach
of deploying configuration
artifacts into the
platform is going
to be very easy,
because you're going
to be able to reuse
whatever you already have.
However, if you're just starting
getting to know agile software
development life
cycles, then you
can adopt something very
easily within the platform.
Just because we're talking
about configuration,
it's going to be way easier
to understand and set up
from zero.
RAYMOND PENG: Perfect, perfect.
OK, thank you.
And then let's take a look at
the next question we've got.
This is a good one, I think.
I was thinking this,
too, as we talked.
My company has several
different businesses,
and they have different types
of security, regulatory,
and compliance requirements.
Can I really make one
global set of policies?
What do you think, Ruben?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Oh,
you can definitely do.
However, depending on the
size of your organization,
you might have to come up with
multiple security patterns.
Remember, and it all comes
down to what you just said,
what kind of requirements
you're getting
and how you're going
to be enforcing them.
So yeah, definitely you
can define global patterns.
However, you might still want to
have that separation of duties,
that separation of concerns so
that the developer doesn't have
to worry about those patterns.
And then someone is going
to be able to enforce
those patterns globally.
That someone might be related to
a business unit, to a project,
not essentially global to
the whole organization,
depending on the size of
the organization, of course.
RAYMOND PENG: And so
with shared flows,
you can create those
reusable, but you don't
have to enforce it globally.
You can make them easy
for teams to add, as well.
And there's a lot of flexibility
to go in and instantiate
different variables
into policies.
RUBEN GONZALEZ: Exactly.
You can either give the
option to developers
to actually enforce that
policy if you want to
and do some checks
before deployment.
Or you can enforce
them globally.
Again, there are
different ways to do it.
But the beauty of the
Apigee Edge platform
is that you do
have those options.
You can build your
own custom way
of enforcing these policies, and
onboarding your developers so
that they understand how
they're being applied.
RAYMOND PENG: OK, great.
I see another question here.
I think we've covered
it, but I think
it's a really good question
just to reinforce again.
The question is, does
Apigee provide any tools
for CI/CD, code quality,
or test automation?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: So yeah,
remember, everything
that you saw today in
the demo, everything
from the clicks I did, from the
developer review, everything,
there's an API behind it.
So the Apigee Edge
platform has been
built for it to be extensible.
So our customers
use Maven plugins
for them to be able to deploy
configuration artifacts.
They use JavaScript
tools to deploy, and also
to test the custom
code that they
deploy within the platform.
So out there, you will
have multiple options.
And of course, we also have
a very strong community
of developers.
All our customers are
always engaging with us
and also setting up some
questions in our Apigee
community.
And of course, there's a
lot of knowledge out there.
And a lot of open [INAUDIBLE]
of solutions that even
between customers,
they start sharing
and reusing and contributing.
RAYMOND PENG: Perfect.
It's certainly a broad
community to leverage
within Apigee and outside.
So number four, in
terms of question,
how big is the center
of enablement team?
First of all, thank you
for using that language,
and starting to
think about that.
Center of enablement
team, we see, varies.
But we generally
see a small group
within the central team
focused on evangelism,
setting standards, and
coaching and supporting others.
We're looking at probably a
handful of people in terms
of the center of enablement.
From there, we see it varying
in terms of how many API
teams you're supporting.
If you've got 10 or
hundreds of API teams,
obviously, your
center of enablement's
probably going to have to
scale up, but over time.
So I don't think this is
about creating a big team.
It's really creating a central
team to set the standards
and start to coach and enable
other teams to grow quickly.
And there's-- I think this is
the last question we've gotten.
So it's a great
question to end with.
The question is, do I need
a dedicated security person
on the API governance team?
What do you think, Ruben?
RUBEN GONZALEZ: That's a
very interesting question.
Most likely, there's someone
within your organization,
and you're going
to get to meet him
once you try to deploy
something into production.
And again, this varies as well
on the sizes of organizations.
However, sometimes if
your team is too small
or the organization is too
small, then most likely
the developer will share
that responsibility.
However, the best
practice is, of course,
from a security standpoint, to
have that separation of duties,
so that then someone can focus
only on the right security
patterns, and the developers
can focus on the real business
value that you want to expose.
RAYMOND PENG: Yeah.
So if we have that
separation of concerns,
I'd say when you start out with
setting up your API management
platform, this is
the perfect time
to invite the security
person to the table.
Let's not meet them at the
very end, like Ruben said.
I think let's make friends
from the very beginning
and have security at the table,
designing and architecting
the platform with us
together, and then
build those policies and
the approach and quality
into the platform and
into basically every API
[INAUDIBLE] deployed.
And so with that, I think
that's the end of our webcast.
I hope you guys got a
lot out of this webcast.
And thank you all
for taking the time
and joining with
Ruben and I today.
Thank you all.
RUBEN GONZALEZ:
Thank you all, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]